how are you guys doing great
i want to start with congratulations on
the movie um
i love learning about like the behind
the scenes how can i curse the behind
the scenes stuff about the making of a
movie i'm curious for all three of you
what do you think fans would be
surprised to learn about the making of
this halloween film
well oh my god we have different answers
yeah
yeah um um
what would fans be surprised to learn
you know like something cool from the
making of the film too oh i i know
something i could say yeah please you
know when they first asked me to do this
david
our director
said you know you need to know about the
scene going into it before you say yes
and the swamp scene he said i want you
to know that there could be alligators i
saw a behind the scenes thing i watched
that we had to approve them and they
should alligators
and she was like what are those guys
doing remember that night yeah well and
then you know i'm looking over it's 3 30
in the morning and i'm like
okay i've got to do this this is like
i have been just been building up and
i'm getting scared i look i see three
men with like rubber pants on
and like whatever those i don't think
they're called overpants but whatever
and then flashlight
with the flashlight looking for
alligators
yeah and i was like so i went up to the
alligator handler
and i said what are the chances that
there's really going to be an alligator
in there with me and he said well if i
were you it was the snakes i'd be more
worried about and i was like no
no not the snakes and michael myers on
top of everything
when you see her performance and how
amazing it is in that scene we know that
she was truly terrified but not of
michael myers it was a snake's an
alligator it was a lot
i didn't know that either until i
watched that behind the scenes footage
they sent us and i was like
i can't believe they did that to her i
totally remember that night yeah because
i had to leave a little early and you
were left with the alligators there that
way we're gonna take every precaution
that a big movie would take and i i was
like what what do they do if there's if
i get snatched up by an alligator
uh the thing what i'm fascinated by is
uh halloween has been popular the
franchise has been popular since the 70s
and this character what do you think it
actually is about michael myers and the
halloween franchise that has resonated
for so long with so many people
well he's really scary and no one can
seem to kill him
so that's pretty um relatable
for all generations
and you're like at universal studios and
they're you know the characters and
they're hired to chase you around on a
horror night it's the same like you
don't know like you know
it can happen to anybody so you can feel
like that's what i think it's so scary
about like halloween trick-or-treating
like you don't know who's really in
those masks if they're really as a
psychopath so yeah go to one of those
cons and everyone's dressed up and has a
backpack on their back and they're like
we're all going to die there like 100
like how is this okay
i saw an interesting interview with
david actually was watching yesterday
and he was just saying there's actually
a limited mythology about myers we don't
know really what makes him tick but i
just think that idea of he's everywhere
what the boogeyman represents right he
could be waiting for you to be under
your bed and
it's incredible you know i think just
that idea that he embodies evil and
freaks everybody out that he's always
lurking you know it's interesting there
are some i'm going to use the term
vicious kills in this movie oh yeah like
some very impressive very impressive
kills uh was there one in particular
that you were like
i have one um when
i dylan arnold and i became friends and
we live in the same neighborhood and i
saw this film and i saw his kill and i
texted him immediately and said your
mother cannot watch this movie i'm so
sorry and tell her i said hi but there's
no way your mom can see this and he was
like noted and he hadn't seen the movie
yet and then when he did see it he was
like oh yeah no my mom can't watch this
movie it was so gruesome i mean michael
killed him for his character for like i
think he killed him like it just went on
and on and on but any time
the sound design of this movie with the
kills like the sound of the blood
squirting out of people's wounds like
the the sound of the bones breaking the
knife going in and then coming out like
i don't like the eyeballs the eyeballs
that will freak me out yeah yeah
the use of a halogen light all kinds of
stuff oh yeah very very uh inventive
kills so quick and creative michael he
is he's such a creative guy
he's like an artist stabs either he
still goes in for those too i feel like
it says a lot about chris nelson our um
the guy who did all the effects and all
the makeups he comes up with
like he and david gordon green the
director like they just get together and
they're like how are we gonna kill this
person how are we gonna kill this person
because ultimately chris is the one that
has to do it so it's like he wants it to
be fun for him and
he's a sick you might be a sick person
on that note um i just wanted to
congrats on the film thank you so much
for giving me your time thank you
you